[Music]
oh
hey i'm sorry
[Music]
hello there this is our final meetup to
look over the fortnite and batman
crossover comic book series
this should be the end but i don't think
it is
you'll get what i mean very soon this is
the series in which we break down
everything that happened to the caped
crusader and what that means for the
storyline of fortnite battle royale
so sit your butt down for 10 minutes and
enjoy a few terrible jokes
think about using code adamaru to help
me pay my bills and if you're ready
let's do this
batman fortnite zero point
a quick recap a mysterious crack in time
and space
appeared in gotham city batman found
himself kicked into it
alongside harley quinn now in the loop
and unable to speak
batman creates a bond with catwoman
without ever saying a word
and the two somehow figure out how to
escape fyi
is being the last alive in the very
center of the final storm circle
now out of the loop the two can speak
and join other survivors
but everyone is missing their memories
using those bunkers we've seen for years
they break into an underground facility
seemingly run by a mysterious group
called io finding the zero point the
group realizes they can go back home
some make it back to their home worlds
and others are cut
into a thousand pieces just as this
whole thing reached a resolution
a sudden double cross from deathstroke
left batman and catwoman stranded
and unable to get home but luckily they
have the portal device
now issue six the final part of the
story and yep
the portal device is broken the zero
point is permanently stuck on the island
which is now
officially referred to as the loop
batman tells us that we need three
people from the home world to
recalibrate the zero point
and remembers harley quinn the woman who
has repeatedly beat him senseless
and how she is likely from his homeworld
selena feels the same too
and the duo go back into the loop and
attempt to recruit harley
can we note that batman is daydreaming
about harley quinn flossing
the world's greatest detective is
thinking about this
hmm okay buddy here's a very interesting
part the duo are worried about returning
to the loop and losing their memories
but we already know this is not a
concern
back during the zero point crisis event
jones told us that without the portal
device he would lose his memory
so as long as batman or selena has that
device they're gonna be fine
the bigger question right now is if the
portal device will allow more than one
person to retain their memories and the
ability to speak
only one way to find out they yeet
themselves back into the loop
and as predicted there is no confusion
there is no memory loss
batman deduces the worst case scenario
is spending too long here and slowly
losing their minds
just like thor the god of thunder and
comic books our heroes
set out to find harley hitching a ride
and thanking the bus driver the duo
scan for quinn who can be found beating
the crap out of nobody's favorite
characters
cuddle team leader ruckus and the king
of the wild west mancake
without hesitation the spandex team
attempt to subdue harley
wait up a sec okay dc and fortnite i'm
all for these shots of ladies butts
and um other things but can we get some
gender equality here
maybe a bit of a bat booty please oh
yeah
oh so sexy well that was weird bats and
cats are using non-lethal moves and
catwoman proves that she's a real
fortnite gamer whether i tagged her call
and then boots are in the boob
harley isn't going without a fight and
gives batman more ptsd with another
no-shuttering strike
if only we could make her understand we
want to take her home batman proclaims
suddenly harley replies or maybe you
numbskulls could figure out that i don't
want to go
whoa whoa pause a sec how is this
possible there's a few ways this could
happen
we have witnessed some npcs having the
ability to talk
largely thought to be something they
lose over time again like
thor indeed oh this could be due to
harley being close to the portal device
that would also explain why batman can
speak when he isn't in contact with it
officially harley tells us she can speak
because she's amazing
and i think it's hard to disagree bruce
explains the plan to go home and harley
thinks over the offer
but shuts it down she likes living in
the loop she likes causing mayhem
constantly she's happy here and to
compound all that
batman takes one to the family jewels
don't expect any baby bat kids anytime
soon celina
[Music]
who's a thunk it it turns out batman
doesn't like being kicked in the nuts
and uses gender equality to knock out
harley quinn
bruce picks up quinn and as catwoman is
about to use a device
just like we saw johnsy do many times
before here's another bombshell
another batman another catwoman and look
b-tech
wish versions of bane and the joker
explosions
i have no idea what the explosions are
bane a long battle ensues as both sides
are perfectly matched
we now receive confirmation from the
world's greatest detective that
snapshots are created by the island
and can vary greatly this snapshot
created battle armor far beyond
our own batman you could say this batman
is built different
i'm built different but strangely these
snapshots cannot speak
i tried to figure out why that was and
maybe snapshots can never speak
but the original versions of each
character can not great
but it works batman throws down the
flashbang as selena opens the rift to go
back
to the zero point
[Music]
reconnecting the energy supply and
relocating their homeworld
batman sets up an explosive batarang to
close the portal the moment they leave
catwoman attempts to convince batman to
stay in this world and be happy together
it seems like selena has an irrational
feeling that something bad will happen
if they return home one thing this
series has told us
every touching moment is broken up by
violence and this is the case this time
harley quinn awakes gives him a quick
beating and then runs away
we should note that she's technically
outside the loop right now
and unless she finds someone else she
will live here alone
forever man that's a scary thought see
you later flossing girl
selena continues to push batman to stay
here and be happy together
just like their snapshots were the
thought that their memories returning
will end up seeing them on opposing
sides
is torture to catwoman she doesn't want
to lose the relationship they've built
whilst here
batman admits to feeling the same way
but he's batman
and he's got to do the right thing and
the right thing is going back to gotham
they jump through the zero point never
to return to the island or the loop
the batarang beeps ready to explode they
made it
and the explosion closes the rift they
did it successful mission
and suddenly all their memories come
flooding back
every time they've encountered each
other from wedding rings to separation
their entire lives changed in a moment
selena walks away
we should have stayed batman is all
somber now and depressed and speaks to
commissioner gordon who thanks him for
closing the rift and saving the city
this is the end of the story in gotham
but over in metropolis
things are evolving
at lex corp everyone's favorite slap
head is speaking to deathstroke
this whole thing was a ruse deathstroke
was sent in to provoke batman into
finding a way back to gotham
while at the zero point he set up a
secret device to link metropolis
to the zero point and the loop lex wants
to harness its power
and then another voice joins the
conversation the real mastermind here
the batman who laughs if you don't know
him he's
a relatively new villain who's both the
joker and the batman
in one
[Laughter]
he's the key bad guy in the multiverse
timelines along with lex
which perfectly fits into the fortnite
story batman who laughs has an iconic
red and black speech bubble in all dc
comics which remains here in the
fortnite series too
i love that touch but there's another
person at this meeting
someone from the imagined order dr
sloan alongside an io guard sloan is
aligning herself with the two most evil
men in dc history
lex points out a bit of law for us
confirming that io
are called they by the natives and it
seems like an incidental comment but by
going back through the story and
fortnite history
we can take the word they and replace it
with io
remember when the seven left us this
message what the seven of us are
attempting
is very risky i suspect
they are not the only ones watching but
it must be done
or we lose the bridge forever so the
watchers are the imagined order so i
wonder if this is the bridge
the zero point could be it we won't go
down that rabbit hole today
i do plan on going back and finding all
the references today
to see if adding io changes the context
at all
but yeah that's a video for another day
let's crack on the story ends with sloan
telling lex to look outside
a new rift has opened here in metropolis
a tear bigger than any we've seen before
the final line confirms this is only the
beginning
far from the end
so it looks like superman's arrival this
season was always part of the plan by
lex luthor
and io and the batman who laughs are all
in on this
i guess we should look out for these
skins in future and of course this
season's unlockable skin
superman himself everything here is
screaming for another crossover season
like we had with marvel
a few months back what do you think
about that what do you think about more
dc content and what do you think about
this six part series
i'd love to know your thoughts i'm adam
you're awesome thanks for going on this
journey with me
i'll be in the comments seeing who has
the best predictions for the future
see you soon thank you called adamaru
legends i'll be back in my dms tonight
to reply to more of you
[Music]